alright thanks Thom you know it's really
great to be back at camp on this campus
college campus campuses specifically
Stanford have like this great optimistic
energy about them so you'll know what I
mean once you graduate and leave and
come back so yeah as Tom said I'm
sha-sha be I'm a explore with National
Geographic so more specifically I'm an
emerging Explorer which is this program
that they have where they look and they
find researchers or scientists or
artists or even engineers that are doing
something that they think could
potentially have a big impact on the
world in the future and they bring them
into their Explorer family so it's a
it's pretty cool and that I get the
opportunity to call myself an explorer
and and other explorers are people that
you all have heard of people like Sylvia
Earle and Jane Goodall and Bob Ballard
and yo Wilson really really cool people
and the other really great thing about
it is it's it's a fairly difficult to
get in you get nominated you can't apply
for it and they do this big betting
thing behind the scenes and give you a
call one day and asked you to be part of
the family which is cool but it also
sometimes ends up people thinking that
they're getting crank called so they
don't take it seriously so so I'm just
going to kind of jump in a little bit
and then I'll talk tell a little bit
about my story but I cannot stress this
enough like we are living in an amazing
remarkable time with opportunity being
literally everywhere which is which is
why I put up this picture because the
time different difference between what
the picture on the left and the picture
on the right is actually not that long
and it's accelerating you know there it
wasn't too long ago where if you wanted
to be an inventor entrepreneur you
couldn't really do it without access to
a factory or a ton of capital but now
you can basically design something and
you know print out a prototype on a 3d
printer and MIT and send that file off
to get printed in a world-class factory
all without leaving your couch so it's
it's a pretty amazing time to be alive
and and that's kind of a theme that's
going to go through this this talk of
mine is is the fact that there's lots of
opportunity out there and it a lot of
that opportunity kind of tends to be in
places where you don't
expect it to be so another speaker that
came to this lecture I think last year
or the year before was the CEO of box
Aaron Levie and yet it he sent out a
tweet the other day that I thought was
awesome he basically said that tech
right now is is basically an
entrepreneurs time machine so every
company and industry created from the
1890s the 1960s is being rebuilt
digitally I would like to add to that to
say that you know there's even
industries and ideas that we haven't
previously thought that Tech had a place
in that betim that are being rebuilt now
but there's a lot of opportunity now and
it's really up to you to take it and you
know Stanford is a wonderful place to do
it this is where my story of this
started and I'll tell you a little bit
about that as i go through but i also
want to say you know being in the
Silicon Valley to try and think beyond
the Silicon Valley bubble there's lots
of issues in this world and lots of
opportunities that need to be fulfilled
by bright minds like yourselves and and
sometimes that's going to happen outside
of the you know San Francisco San Jose
little bubble so so my story now I went
to school for engineering a specific
specifically chemical engineering but
you know I don't know maybe it's like a
lot of you guys but I didn't know what I
wanted to be when I grew up I knew that
I liked technology and I like toys I was
a little kid that was breaking
everything all the electronics of my
parents because I try and take it apart
and then when I went through high school
you know I didn't have a lot of guidance
on what was out there what the
possibilities were out there and I got
into cars and mechanics and you know I
liked chemistry I like physics so I put
those two things together and and I went
to school for chemical engineering so I
you know after I went through my
undergrad I went out there and I started
looking for the jobs out there and and
what I could find for a chemical
engineer really was was only water
treatment jobs and I don't want to i
want to just preface that I think water
treatment is a wonderful career and it
actually winds its way into my story
which is why I brought it up right now
but it wasn't something that I felt
particularly inspired about at that time
so you know I started looking at grad
school and during that time I got an
internship at Boeing so that kind of
brings me to the first
point that I wanted to get across and
that's get industry experience if some
of you guys are earlier in your career I
would say go out there and get an
internship somewhere I know that being
an intern isn't necessarily the most fun
thing with a lot of companies you know
they usually give you the kind of the
crappier things to do it's it's the
thing we're in a company if there's
something you don't want to work on you
just pass along to the intern so they
have to take care of it but I guarantee
even if you're doing crappy things in
that job like the the lessons that you
learn from being in that kind of
industrial setting inside of a company
will stay with you for the rest of your
career so it's definitely something that
I think you should you should push
forward and do and that's what I did
when I got that internship at Boeing I
worked really hard and got hired into
Boeing halfway through through that
internship opportunity and so I want to
stress right now that there's ways that
being entrepreneurial while you're still
at a big company you don't have to do
the startup thing and be an entrepreneur
you can be have an entrepreneurial
mindset when you are working for a large
corporation like Boeing and and the way
that I want to explain that is just kind
of threw this charted if we just imagine
for a second that when you look at a big
company especially one that was like
born of maybe like an older industry so
something like aerospace a big
engineering company a lot of times you
get two main types of people there and
let's call those people techies and
jabbers so jobbers are the people that
come to the come to job come to their
work every day only nine to five and
they just they're coming to it for a
paycheck you know they don't want to get
anything outside of that there's not
anything necessarily wrong with that I
mean there's more to life than just work
but you know that was never me I was
never of that job or type the other
people are the techies and those are the
people you know like the brilliant
engineers the specialists the program
managers the types of people that you
know want to become very very good at
one thing and they care very much about
that but they really don't care about
anything else in the company now the
interesting thing that I've learned
about being in a company full of jobbers
and techies is that you know if your
entrepreneurial minded and you want to
do say
basically both those groups of people
will move move aside and let you do it
they won't stand in your way and if you
do it in the right way and if you think
about it in the you know the correct
method in terms of trying to change
things in a company you can get the
resources of a giant corporation behind
you which can be pretty beneficial so
the opportunities I've had at Boeing in
the last 10 years have been amazing you
know I've been kind of in charge of the
engineering and design for multiple
spacecraft the propulsion system
specifically so I'm a rocket scientists
or propulsion systems engineer you know
I've gotten to be part of a team that
launched over 11 spacecraft and worked
the Mission Control many of those times
I was a lead lead propulsion engineer
for that and when you get to do that you
get to do things like sit cool things
like sit in Mission Control and say
propulsions go for launch you know
countdown so when I did that I could you
know check that off a bucket list that I
didn't know existed because who has that
on a bucket list and and you know I I
got to learn quite a bit about about the
different things that you can do in that
industry it's it's been a really really
wonderful opportunity and then the other
good thing that came out out of being at
a big company was that I got my
education all paid for Boeing had a
phenomenal education program and you
know I went to graduate school at USC n
here at Stanford all without having to
pay a dime so that's really amazing
thing that big corporations allow you to
do because they can kind of absorb those
costs so the one thing I would have to
say though about working at a big
company and though that you really have
to keep track of and make sure it
doesn't happen to you is is get too
comfortable the the problem with working
at a company like that it's very easy
and you know a lot of times it's easy to
go into that comfortable lifestyle and
you know enjoy happy hours and all that
stuff and next thing you know all that
entrepreneurial energy you had deep
inside of you has kind of gone out that
fire is and put out so so the one thing
I would say is kind of hold on to that
fire don't let it go out so I wanted to
talk a little bit about engineering
because this is something that I talk
about a lot
I feel like engineering hat is in a
little bit of a crisis of character but
thankfully now with tech being cooler
it's starting to change a little bit but
I am a firm believer in engineering
ability to change the world and so I'll
talk a little bit about that a lot of
times when people talk about engineers
like when you see how they're portrayed
in the media or on comics and stuff like
that they're always kind of the nerdy
people you know that introverts the the
ones that that don't really talk to
people very well you know they're the
Dilbert for those of you that are old
enough in the audience to know who Dober
is but you know I i want to say
engineers are much more than that you
know Leonardo da Vinci was an engineer
I've Ada Lovelace there you know the
daughter of Lord Byron she was the first
computer programmer and the Wright
brothers technology turns us into a
global society you know so I engineers
are the ones that create the society
that we live in they create this the
built society that you and I enjoy every
single day they give us the tools to
solve humanity's greatest mysteries you
know they save lives there's lots of
stuff that engineering does behind the
scenes so they don't necessarily get
credit for and in my opinion there's a
lot more that you can do with
engineering that we haven't quite tapped
into so including marketing it better so
while I was really excited about the
work I was doing at Boeing and you know
I was technically challenged by that
kind of stuff I still tried to find
something where I felt was maybe more
aligned with kind of the amazing nature
of what an engineer is to me and during
that search is where I found engineers
without borders so I don't know if any
of you guys have heard about engineers
without borders I know Stanford has a
similar organization called engineers
for a sustainable world but basically
it's a humanitarian organization and the
purpose of Engineers Without Borders is
to use engineering to help solve the
problem that we have across a lot of
this planet which is people's lack of
access to things like clean drinking
water sanitation and electricity it's a
really great organization it was started
in 2002 by Bernard Amadeus professor at
University of Colorado Boulder
and when I found out about it I wanted
to learn more and kind of work towards
it so I also know Scott Harrison came
here and he talked about charity water
so you guys might know about a little
bit of the statistics behind what the
problem is but there's over two billion
people this planet that don't have
access to those fundamental human rights
things I clean drinking water and
sanitation it's a really important thing
to work on and so what ewb does or
engineers Without Borders does is they
they basically operate mostly in
professional and student chapters and
and the organization's team up with the
community for a number of years and and
you'll go over to the community first
for a assessment trip and you'll see
like what kind of problems they're
really facing like you know maybe their
drinking water problem is tied to
something else more serious and it's
something that an engineer can come back
and look at then you'll come back and
you'll do you'll do some design and some
analysis with the rest of the team state
with the state's I'd go through a design
review and have a pee or professional
engineer sign off on it and then you'll
go back over into the community and you
actually build what it was that you that
you ended up designing so I've had the
opportunity with engineers without
borders to work on projects in Mali
Malawi tanzania India Thailand and
Mexico so it's been a really cool
opportunity and quite a bit of fun so
that brings me to the second lesson that
I wanted to talk about while I was here
today and that was to to volunteer for
something a lot of times people don't
volunteer because they think that it's
going to take a lot of effort but I want
to stress that like if you put yourself
out there and you find a cause it
doesn't matter what the causes there's
there's so many issues out there that
need our help so if it's something that
speaks to you and doesn't speak to
another person then still go through go
through with it but I really want to
stress that the the feeling that you get
the impact that you get out of working
on something without expecting something
in return it has profound effect on the
person that you are and things that you
end up doing with your life and if you
want to look at this in an
entrepreneurial sort of way if if you
want to end up working on an on this
problem or working in an industry
associated to that problem through
volunteering is you could really start
to understand the
problem more deeply and and gain
credibility in in talking about that so
you know I volunteered for Indian
engineers without borders for a number
of years didn't really have any
expectations other than I wanted to
really do some good work and I wanted to
try and help some people I wanted to
solve that problem that I said about the
two billion people who lack access to
those fundamental human rights and so
basically I went into it and I just I
worked hard on that and I ended up you
know rising up through some of the ranks
in the LA professional chapter and I did
stuff in the regional chapter and it was
a lot of years where I was trying to
convince a lot of the other engineers at
Boeing to come and join me and a lot of
people didn't want to do it because they
were afraid that I was going to take up
too much their time the great thing
about volunteering is that it only takes
up as much of the time as you want to
give it so after years of talking to
everyone about it and telling everyone
at Boeing to join engineers without
borders I actually ended up getting a
little bit of recognition for it and so
Boeing named me their volunteer of the
year their exceptional volunteer of the
year which is out of a hundred and
seventy thousand employees it's the
person who wins that award and and I got
to fly to Chicago and meet with the
executives out there and and have lunch
with the los angeles mayor and lots of
random things like that but but the the
reason why I wanted to bring this up was
because you know in the whole mindset of
using a kind of entrepreneurial thinking
in a big company I use that opportunity
to talk to Boeing talk to the management
at Boeing and kind of convince them that
they need that the the things that
engineers without borders wants to do
and the things that Boeing wants our
kind of one in the same and they should
kind of look at that a little bit more
deeply and they did I mean Boeing ended
up getting behind engineers Without
Borders in a big way after that they
sent their entire Executive Council to
management training which was important
because the ewb grew fast they started
in 2002 and in nine years they start
from one chapter one professor in the
University of Colorado Boulder and in
nine years they had twelve thousand
volunteers as a part of their thing and
they couldn't quite keep up they also
added you know funded some board
positions on on the thing and they and
they gave away 1.1
million dollars in grants to projects so
both ewb and all the communities that
ewb supported were better off as a
result of that but I'm going to tell you
a little bit specifically about one trip
that I took it and this is an
implementation trip to southern Tanzania
so the village we were working in was a
palama you see it up there in the corner
it's about eight hours from Dar aslam
eight very rough hours it's not a not an
easy trip but we were asked to come and
talk to the community and help them with
their problem which was water so this
community is is in the southern
highlands as I said it's a it's a very
hilly terrain it's very different than
any of you guys thinking about the
Serengeti when you think about tanzania
it's completely different environment
down there which also means that it's a
it's a difficult environment for dealing
with the transport of water we were
asked specifically to come to the school
and help with the water situation at the
school so the school is at the highest
point in the village which basically
meant that all the students would have
to spend a couple hours in the beginning
of their days every day hiking down to
the catchment filling up those five
gallon buckets and bringing them up to
the school so they can have enough water
to drink and cook with for the entire
day this was time that the kids should
have been spending in class but they're
really just spending it moving water so
we designed a rainwater catchment and
filtration system luckily the area that
we were working in had ample rain and we
can size this thing big enough that it's
basically will cover a lot of the school
year so that was our plan to go in and
build that thing now we ended up going
to a city of iringa which is nearby it's
kind of the closest construction town in
the area to try and gather some of the
supplies and in doing that we found that
a lot of things that you know our state
side team assumed that would we would
find fairly easily in Tanzania were not
found at all and so we had to do a lot
of kind of re-engineering and
recalculating on the fly which was both
exciting and frustrating at the exact
same time and the roads going back were
very small and kind of curvy and so this
is just a quick snapshot of one of them
but when we
that truck back it had a lot of
difficulties getting around these roads
we had to slow down and take the turns
really really slowly and one of those
turns when we were taking it we ended up
finding a similar truck facing the other
way that was broken down on the inside
of the turn which would not have
normally been a big problem but the the
issue was that the other side was a big
steep drop-off and so we had to figure
out a way to get the truck around the
broken-down truck without falling into
the steep drop-off and the the method
that we ended up using was getting all
all the guys that we had to hang on the
side of the truck that's on the inside
so that as we slowly went around the
truck didn't slide off the side of the
cliff so that picture of 13 guys hanging
on the inside of a truck to keep it from
falling off a cliff it's something that
I won't forget for a very long time and
also the gearbox kept on slipping so as
we're going up these steep inclines we'd
have to repeatedly throw that log
underneath the rear tires it was a bit
really big long process but finally we
ended up getting to the school and
unpacking all the materials and started
on what ended up being a very
frustrating build so things didn't end
up getting any better at this point none
of the tolerances were correct
everything didn't go together the way
that we wanted to the sand for the
filter was way dirtier than we ever
expected it to be and and so it started
to get hard right we were a bunch of
we're for engineers and a bunch of
villagers that were working together on
this thing and tensions were were
getting high and this was mostly because
we didn't know if we can finish the
build and the time that we allotted for
it even down to the nails that we would
use we would try and bang the nails into
the wood and the nail would just bend in
half and shoot off in the distance and
so we started kind of getting a lot of
we were getting there's a high tension
in the in the air about this kind of
build but I do remember one day where we
ended up walking out from the school
yard and I looked over and you kind of
suddenly saw everything sitting up there
finally put together I mean they had
while I was inside working they had put
the tanks up on those stands and that
was the day where it kind of felt like
okay we're going to finish this thing
everyone had this like whole
sense of relief that washed over them
and it was it was a very very happy day
well it turns out that that same day we
ended up being my my birthday maybe I
fell on my birthday so we were there in
Tanzania so so we went back to the house
and we ate the same bland meal that we
ate for lunch and dinner every day but I
remember that meal tasting you know
especially satisfying because where we
were in the building and and that we
would actually finish this in a work so
while we're eating dinner I heard a
bunch of commotion outside and you know
the other engineers told me to go check
it out and I walked out back to find the
entire village in our in the backyard
ready to celebrate my birthday which was
pretty cool the they know birthdays
aren't a big thing for this village so
the other engineers kind of organized
this whole thing but we ended up
spending the entire night you know
dancing to two drums and drinking corn
beer under the most amazing view of the
Milky Way I've ever seen so that's a
birthday that it's going to be tough to
top even if I don't ever want to drink
corn beer ever again who's krause really
bad so you know we finished the project
in time the kids were happy the
principal at the school was was so proud
of the work that we did that he had a
sign a little guest book in his house
and he gifted us one of his price
chickens to take with us and and the
system still works to this day so you
know I just I want to stress that if it
wasn't for volunteering I would have
never had an experience like that you
know i would have never met people like
that so I say to you know go put
yourself out there and and see what's
out there okay so but it wasn't until I
came here until I was at Stanford that I
kind of found what I consider my true
calling so as Tom talked to a little bit
you know while I was here I was taking
grad courses in management science and
engineering and I I ended up taking
Tom's global entrepreneurial marketing
course so I don't know if any of you
guys in here of taking that course yet
but a portion of that is you work on a
project with a company that comes into
the class and you kind of apply
entrepreneurial
thinking to it and as a result of that
you can you end up that ends up being
part of your grade and so when I took
that class there was there was one
nonprofit in the entire class and it was
the Center for ocean solutions which is
a Stan Stanford based organization and
and the problem they wanted us to look
at was the problem of illegal fishing so
you know like many of you I probably
didn't know very much about illegal
fishing I knew that there was probably
some shady fishermen out there and that
it was probably contributing to the
problem the problem of overfishing in
the world but I didn't realize like what
a big problem it actually was I mean we
it's a it's a 23 billion dollar industry
illegal fishing is you know since the
1950s when we kind of invented this
modern way of fishing ninety percent of
the big fish in the world have been just
have disappeared you know that's tuna
and shark and everything everyone likes
to eat you know our current global
fishing fleets are two and a half times
what our planet can sustainably handle
and and and we're just seeing things
getting worse we're seeing you know fish
stocks crashing left and right and the
worst part about this is that most of it
targets developing nations which kind of
robs the poorest people the planet of
their food and their income and a lot of
times they'll even take those people and
they'll put them on the boats as fishers
and a lot of these vessels act
essentially as slave ships they don't
let the people off the boats they're out
at seas for a long time they just dump
their catch at sea on bigger container
vessels and barely pay these people
anything so it's actually a human rights
issue as well and two billion people on
this planet rely on our oceans for their
for their primary source of food and
income the primary source of protein so
it's a it's a big thing and and lastly I
I know you guys have probably heard of
the piracy problem that we have in
Somalia well you know that piracy
problem really came from this the guys
who are now pirates the Somalians who
are now pirates were originally
fishermen and basically illegal fishing
off the coast of Somalia was ramp
there was lots of Italian vessels that
were fishing quite aggressively out
there and they were dumping pollution
into the washer at waters and it
basically turned all that water over
there until wasteland and so you know
you have boats and guns and no
government and so what do you do you
pump pirate and that's kind of where
that that whole thing happened it's
really sad so me and two other
individuals wanted to work with Center
for ocean solutions on this problem and
we thought that maybe the right answer
to the problem was in technology so
basically the way that we protect our
coasts now is the same way we've
protected them for you know centuries
it's essentially most of the time what
we do is we'll get in a boat and we'll
just shoot out there until we randomly
find someone doing something they
shouldn't be doing and then they get in
trouble for it which is crazy and so we
thought that there's much better ways to
do this there's there's a lot of
opportunity in this you know and so we
ended up working on the project and and
I was so inspired by that work that I
asked the Center for ocean solutions if
I can continue on as an independent
researcher for a number of quarters and
I did that for for three more quarters
and then after that I just started
working working on it for from my career
so that's kind of where conservation
technologies what I call it now that's
where conservation technology came from
that's where my passion for that came
from and so that brings me to the next
lesson that I wanted to share and that's
opportunity exists everywhere and you
know I wanted to stress this because you
know when I first started this if you
would have came to me 10 years ago and
told told me you know what Shaw Selby I
believe that you're going to be working
on helping wildlife populations in the
world I would probably say to you that I
don't have the skills to do that you
know and then I would never have found
out 10 years later that I I actually
precisely have some of the skills that
can help solving some of those problems
so this is an area where i didn't know
opportunity exists and it wasn't until I
said you know what I'm going to take
this class and I'm going to do this
illegal fishing project that i found
that there was this huge potential there
so that could be in all each of every
one of your lives so if i want you to
all
look back at your careers and what you
want to end up doing with your with your
life and think hard and long about
opportunity and where that exists you
know because so often the limits that we
put on opportunity are the ones that you
know we put on ourselves or society
tells us that it's there and it takes a
little while but until you stand up and
say it enough times that people say oh
yeah you're right there is a lot of
opportunity there so a story about that
is you know they're there was a time
where I was sitting in this meeting and
it was full of kind of some marine
biologists and environmental lawyers and
they're all talking about the big
problems that our oceans are facing and
it was in that meeting where I started
seeing the things that they're saying
and I i started thinking me you know
that seems like there's a non
engineering solution there or you know
they if they only look at what they did
in the shipping industry that could
probably help that problem or here's
this little technology that we can fill
this gap and it was there where I kind
of you know I was aware that opportunity
can exist anywhere and it was from then
that I've kind of moved on through that
so I got to go with Stanford to Palau
and we presented an entrepreneurship
seminar there a conference there and I
gave a technology plan to the president
of Palau which is pretty cool I work
with the Waitt Institute on a on a
project that they're doing in barbuda
and they're expanding it beyond just
barbuda but it's kind of a comprehensive
mapping of the science and legislation
and and usage of the ocean around the
island so it's really neat thing to be
able to create all of that stuff from
scratch I work with the XPrize to help
them map out what the next three grand
ocean challenges will end up being and
and it's this conservation technology
work that ended up in me being named one
of the National Geographic emerging
explorers so this problem is really
really important and the reason why is
because it's it's kind of out of control
nowadays so in the last 40 years we've
lost over fifty percent of the wild life
on this planet in the last 40 years and
it's happening so fast that it's having
a lot of people start to call it the
sixth extinction so if you don't know
much about the history of you know
on this planet if we've kind of gone
through five major extinctions Ice Age
and things like that but those other
five extinctions were caused by
asteroids or natural phenomenon and the
sixth one is caused by all of us in this
room so the illegal wildlife trade is
the fourth most lucrative trade and the
planet after drugs human trafficking and
arms weapons 35,000 250 thousand
elephants are poached annually just for
their ivory so in the last hour you know
we've been up for after the last hour
four of them have to have died for
rhinos are poached every day and you
know these are small populations there's
five northern white rhino remaining and
there's 35 javan rhino remaining and
there's more Tigers in backyard of
people in the US and they're only wild
so to kind of like work on this I have
started conservative of Phi which is
like an organization that's focused on
bringing some of these ideas to fruit so
it's kind of like an idea lab so a
nonprofit that works on kind of focusing
how whatever you need to do to develop
and test and put these out in the world
a lot of that stuff is focused around
open source approaches because I find
it's easier to replicate and adapt as
needed one of the projects of that is
sore ocean which is a grant or a project
that's funded by National Geographic and
and lindblad expeditions to use you know
these low-cost drones that you guys
always hear about all over the news for
ocean conservation causes we've done a
bunch of expeditions off the coast and
I'm going to do one i'm going to show a
video of one of the expedition's right
now
I'm Shelby I'm an engineer and ocean
conservation technologists and an
emerging explore with the National
Geographic Society this weekend were in
San Simeon on this beautiful coastline
of California we're here because I'm
principal investigator for a program
called sore ocean which is a grant
that's funded by National Geographic and
lindblad expeditions to use low-cost UAV
or drone technology to monitor and
protect our oceans the value in using
UAV technology or drone technology for
ocean purposes is there's there's a lot
of reasons why we need to get an aerial
vantage point in order to collect more
data about our ocean and something that
I I specifically focus on is how to stop
things like illegal fishing and poaching
of our ocean wildlife it's often way too
expensive to fly a manned aircraft and
the resources are limited a lot of times
this role falls to the military but i
believe that communities can be
empowered to collect the necessary data
and help the authorities to better
protect these delicate species that we
have in our coasts hi my name is Patrick
Meyer and National Geographic emerging
explorer which is how I know Sean was
also
explore we met last year and we
immediately hit it off we've both got a
passion for civilian UAVs or non-lethal
Jones except I come to this place from
the humanitarian side of things i work
in humanitarian innovation through
technology and i'm here this weekend to
really learn as much as I can't hands-on
from cumshaw and his team of experts in
this civilian UAV space and then learn
what it means to deploy UAVs and
settings like the one we're at here
which is somewhat remote and isolated
you don't have all the tools and
electricity and everything else you
might need which is very similar to sue
a humanitarian setting and how do we how
do we still deploy these UAVs in a
timely way and it really behooves us to
go beyond our own field and to talk and
interact with experts in other fields
like Environmental Conservation ocean
protection and learn how they're using
new technologies like UAV so I'm very
excited about about the future of this
innovation technology in the
humanitarian settings I think it will
literally help us save lives and
alleviate suffering where people need it
the most so there's going to be a number
of different expeditions this is this is
the first of at least three with with
the ultimate goal of ending up in the
Channel Islands to to try and show the
power of using these low-cost versions
of drones in in long endurance flights
of patrolling our oceans so a lot of the
information behind that's coming out
pretty shortly so you can follow it on
twitter if you want to find out more
information but another project or that
we worked on was how you can use kind of
crowd sourcing to help protect the coast
so you guys have heard of like citizen
science and this is like citizen
protection so create the tools and the
ways that people can work together to
create like the neighborhood watch for
the Seas this program has been folded in
something else that we're working on now
that will be coming out shortly and then
the final thing that I work on is a lot
of different types of sensors and other
kind of open devices that allow us to
understand more about the environment
and help us protect the environment so
I'm going to show a quick video about
one of those projects
then tell you some stories about that
the gallery
is the birthplace of of argument
existence it's the sanctuary of the San
Bushmen convert 200,000 years ago to
populate our planet and result in all of
us
you come out here
to be part of
the cycle of death the Okavango Delta is
our mother mother of the by a truck we
depend in the Okavango Delta all the
food we help we get it from Delta the
source of your kavango river is on the
bay plateau near golden Madam's this
river then flows 1,000 miles down
through Namibia into northern Botswana
where it finds itself in a delta middle
of the Kalahari Desert
27 years of war ended in 2002 the
development in Angola since then has
been rapid we're looking at the
potential dance for agricultural
developments for pumping schemes all of
these things are going to change the Fed
dynamic in the sensitive wetland
ecosystem if what time disappeared Alex
are the won't survive any more animals
as well the won't survive because they
what are dependent the urgency is now we
are taking dugout canoes on my quarterly
it's our team down the length of your
ganga river the idea of it seems like
madness never forget me
Oh to make sure that you keep your eyes
open but that you know where they are or
you listen very well to hear big one in
front
coming around coming around we've been
living out here used to sounds of hippos
like you can hear behind me right now
use the sounds of elephants in the
distance trumpeting about there who
knows what and we've been part of it in
an incredible way this place is really
I want to work to make this place stay
the way it is to help this place anyway
I can we can bring that place back we
can turn it again into the elephant
factory sapphic in the famous dictum
henry david thoreau
wildness is the preservation of
humankind is the very pulse of this
planet and when we lose these last
walking serious like the Okavango Delta
we lose the beating heart of our planet
so I don't know how many you guys know
about the Aqua Bongo Delta that's a kind
of a good summary on it but it's in
Botswana and it's easily one of the most
amazing places on this planet there's
lots of concern for the development
that's happening in Angola there's if
you go to the capital Angola it's
actually more expensive than many
European cities that you go to because
of the amount of development and amount
of people who are in coming to that city
but that's the this is the Aqua Vanga
wilderness project and so the project
lead was Steve boys the person that you
saw talking he's a TED fellow and
biologist he does this multi-year
expedition and the Okavango to do
surveys of birds and other map mammals
the other guy you heard talking was a
Greg trench and he was a national
geographic adventure of the year he runs
an organization that does put scientists
in touch with adventurers that are going
to go climb Everest in other places to
get really hard too hard to find data
and jer thorp is kind of the the data
artist he's a brilliant data artist that
runs an organization that's rethinking
how we're consuming information and
everything and i'm the project
technologist so I helped to kind of
figure out what technologies we can use
to monitor the Delta and make sure that
that doesn't actually happen so we in
doing this we kind of wanted to change
the way that scientific expeditions are
usually run in the past scientists would
go out on an expedition and they would
gather a bunch of data and they kind of
sit on it and wait on it to publish it
and gain all these accolades when we
went on this expedition and when we go
on future expeditions we want to do
exactly the opposite we kind of wanted
to open it up for the world so we we put
all the water quality readings the
sensor readings the wildlife sightings
biometrics and all this other data out
there for use for free on the website
and and through the API so people can
take it and do interesting things with
it we were
looking to kind of open source the
expedition and we're hoping that we can
you know that the accolades can come
from the amazing things that citizen
scientists or artists or researchers or
students or anybody wants to do with it
so as I said I'm building kind of these
sensors and they're in there based off
of kind of open source microprocessor
platforms and they send the data real
time to to the website for this last one
we put just a handful of sensors kind of
prototype versions up in different parts
but this next year's expedition
deploying an entire mesh network across
the Delta to to gather the information
that we need but I want to talk a little
bit about the expedition itself because
those 17 days were the greatest
adventure I've ever been on my entire
life I'm not sure if you got it from the
from the video itself but this was not
an easy trek this was pretty crazy we
were we were in boats in little canoes
like that surrounded by hippos and lions
and elephants and and crocodiles without
a gun or anything like that and so we
had to be pretty careful and not only
that but we had to pull the boats over
water for a number of days three days
this last expedition it could be as much
as nine days and there's only a handful
of people in the world that know how to
get to this really pristine area on land
or on water and they were our guides for
this expedition you know during what we
were dragging that the boats over water
we were walking through things like this
and there was one moment where I lifted
my feet out of the water and I had nine
leeches on my legs at once which was
pretty interesting five on one leg and
four on the other but we got we got
through all these reeds and all this
papyrus and we got to the pretty much
the most pristine area I've ever known
and I've never seen in my entire life is
it was so much wildlife there felt like
you're in the middle of a Disney movie
but you could see right here this is
just the front of a huge herd of
elephants or was around 50 elephant
there but also in that picture we have
crocodile hippos leche and birds and
this was everywhere we looked just right
after this picture you see a piece of it
in the video but the elephants and the
hippos
you know basically gone into an attack
on each other which is pretty amazing
just to see right in front of you is
like you're watching a planet earth
documentary but it was literally in
front of you and so I don't know how
much how much you guys know about hippos
but they kill more people in Africa than
anything any other animal out there they
are horrible they're scary so and we
were charged by a number of them the the
thing that hippos do is a there was
sounds of it in the video but basically
they start they sit at you and look at
you like this and they grunt and they
make this noise it's like I mean it's
kind of a grunt and it's kind of like an
old man laughing if you if you put both
those together and then when they want
to charge you they drop to the bottom of
the water like onto the the bottom of
the channel and they run so you see the
head you hear the grunting and then you
see awake moving towards you and you
just have to kind of move as fast as you
could possibly move but the experiences
we had with elephants were amazing to
this picture was taken we were setting
up camp one day and our expedition
photographer James kid came over and he
told me oh there's you know three adults
and a baby right over there on the other
side of the trees and so I walked over
to this tree that I thought was kind of
along the path where they would walk and
I climbed up into the tree and I started
taking pictures and it you know slowly
one by one each one of the elephants
walked right past me it was one of the
most amazing experience I ever had in my
entire life I felt like nothing else in
the world existed except for me in these
these magnificent elephants but the last
one was a bull and he looked over at me
and did kind of this aggressive behavior
that they sometimes do where they lift
up their foot and they flap out their
ears and in that moment I went from
feeling the most amazing experience I've
ever felt to being most scared I've ever
been in my entire life I've never felt
more small than sitting on that tree and
that thing looking at me but it
obviously kind of thought it was not
very interesting and just walked away so
the final lesson that I want to bring to
this class is I want to say find your
inspiration and that the world needs you
I think that all you guys can can
potentially find something that inspires
you as much as kind of conservation and
Technology inspires me it's all out
there for each and every one of you you
start looking and try things and so I
basically plead you to go out there and
put yourself out there and try and fail
and pick yourself back up and keep on
working on it the world actually needs
your help we we need you so instead of
thinking of entrepreneurship and
engineering and innovation in terms of
maybe building a better app that can
filter things better than Instagram I
want you to think about the grand
challenges that our planet is facing and
what you can do to kind of change those
challenges what you can do to to start
companies or start nonprofits that can
really change the tide on where we're
going you know because because we need
you to do it maybe by doing it you can
inspire the next generation of engineers
and scientists that go off and and
change the world and maybe we won't
leave this planet off as badly as it
seems like we're we're starting to put
it so thank
when almost every single bit okay and
he's given into climbing the ladder and
joining air forming a mini pocket I so
the question was there's kind of this
rat race in the corporate world that
basically is the reason why a lot of
Engineers didn't want to volunteer
alongside me and the question was how I
was able to be able to do all this stuff
while working in corporate America and I
guess my only answer was was that I
found something that I was passionate
and inspired by and so it I'm not going
to lie i work very long nights and
weekends on things and sometimes it
feels like I'm doing two full-time jobs
but but I'm in a position where I feel
so inspired that sometimes it doesn't
matter and then you know as you as you
kind of work hard toward something I
mean you see this in entrepreneurship
right like entrepreneurs say this if
you're working hard towards an idea you
have times where you feel like it's the
greatest idea in the world and you have
times where you feel like you're an
idiot you know and so it kind of goes
through these waves and and that that's
the same thing that happens when you're
working on anything you know especially
things like this and you just got to
kind of convince yourself to work
through it you know there's work through
the stressful times and keep on pushing
and maybe eventually you can get there
while the end of the project you showed
us and Africa how much would you say to
you learn during your studies and how
much you learned like during during the
dog so the question was like in in in
pertaining to the project in Africa how
much I learned when I was studying and
how much I learned in my job I learned
it all on the job I you know I so I'm an
engineer and I know engineering
principles and I've worked in industry
as an engineer and I understand like
kind of how to go about those problems
and you know I've learned a lot of that
stuff from school my my master's degree
was in systems engineering so I've I
know how to look at things from a
systems perspective and you know boiled
down the requirements and everything
like that so I use that in this stuff
but the technology itself I mean most of
it I've kind of just learned from
working with people or the internet I
mean you know we're that's part of the
whole we're living in this amazing time
right we have the opportunity to learn
these things and if you hang out around
like maker spaces or anything like that
most of people that are building
interesting things in a lot of the maker
spaces are not engineers you know
they're just random people who have
figured out how to build something and
they're buying hardware and doing it so
the drone technology that you mentioned
it or you suck showed us in that one
video is their plan how do you plan to
spread that what's the their model for
selling that too
toots how what do you do to that grown
feeling so so the part that was already
funded was to put together all the
information around it what limitations
are like operations kind of lessons
learned everything and and through the
expeditions and all that stuff's going
to go on the source and website so it's
effectively going to be open for anybody
who wants to use it and do anything with
it now what's or oceans going to do
beyond that is probably work on creating
some off-the-shelf drones for specific
uses that they can do I don't want to
build my own drone I there's a billion
companies doing that nowadays but
configuring it in the correct way and
and deploying it is something that
there's a ton of interest in so yeah
that's what a conservative phone is
going to be it's a non-profit so it's
going to eventually kind of there's some
things and work to move into doing that
in a bigger scale so oh that the
question was am I going to start this as
a non-profit or just do it on the
volunteering side and I and I said that
it is it is a non-profit is moving
towards the kind of much bigger
operation so that's the plan for 2015 um
washed dishes about stopping this
illegal fishing problem yeah so the
question was more more suggestions about
stopping the legal fishing problem so
the number one thing I can tell you guys
that you should do is is download the
Seafood Watch app from Monterey Bay
Aquarium and don't eat the things that
are read on it like that's the easiest
thing that you can do it's super easy to
do it there's a lot of information a lot
of great books and documentaries that
have been done it on in it I've you know
me personally I know so much about that
kind of stuff because i've been working
in it so long that I'm the guy that
nobody ever invites to sushi but but
like you know you can do much less than
that and still have a positive impact
right and
there's this great push for seafood
traceability and understanding where it
came from catch to plate basically and
through using things like seafood watch
your you're reinforcing that you know
and asking I mean you can ask
restaurants where they got their fish a
lot of times they don't know or they'll
tell you something that you they think
you want to hear but if enough people do
that then it can kind of be a bigger
movement so just be clear about
something so good is the drug thing
supposed to like have it like regularly
like far as people suppose like two
rounds to control yeah well so the
question was about the drone thing and
how it works operationally so so yet you
can patrol with like a fixed-wing that's
got a longer range on it it obviously
it's going to be more near shore stuff
right now while all the Endurance's are
lower and then quadcopters would be more
for like technical type evidence
gathering so that's that's the model as
of right now what we see is hosting a
police usually after your career here
so the question was what would I say
like the the ultimate legacy or impact
that I want my career to have I the
number one that's super easy I want
engineers to start thinking about
problems outside of what what school has
told them are the only problems they can
work on I want interdisciplinary
thinking between engineering and the
rest of the world I you know I think
that there's a great potential there's a
lot of people doing really stupid things
now that if you just had someone who had
a different perspective come in and say
just check it out and look at how
they're doing it they might you know be
able to save a lot of resources change
you know change things that they're
doing and potentially you change the
world yeah I mean I think that through
doing that through collaborating with
each other we can do quite a bit so I'd
love to inspire other engineers to do
the same thing that's what I would like
to do oh and stop all the wildlife crime
if I could do that but you know it's a
little difficult I'm sorry okay it was a
energy did how effective is the
initiative for conservation I mean it's
been it's been huge there's not I mean
there's tons of nonprofits that want to
work on it we have pilot projects that
are working all over the place there's
the when I first started talking about
the stuff nobody was talking about
technology and constipation there's very
few people but they were looking at
companies that already produced things
and everything was overpriced and it
didn't really work very well now it's I
mean you know Google's looking at
different ways that they can help and
stuff so i think i think it's been huge
over the last couple of years the
changes that we see so we'll see we'll
see how things go in the future you know
this stuff's kind of takes a little wild
and go through and make a difference
please almost all the time field but
they say it's sure to pick up yourself
your challenge yeah so the the thing was
to talk about my failures a little bit
because I think the way that maybe this
sounded was that I haven't had a billion
failures which I failed more than
anything else I've failed way way way
more than I succeeded I basically every
time I try something and it didn't work
I just kind of started again the next
day to try over so based every single
project you had There was just riddled
with failure I just didn't let it affect
myself you know so I don't want to I
mean failure is a part of this whole
thing it's the way that you move forward
you can't nobody ever creates anything
without failing before and if you do
you're very lucky and I'd like to meet
you but yeah okay are you guys building
creative models based on when you catch
illegal activity on the Seas and using
that to target your petroleum efforts a
little bit more okay so the question was
are we looking at predictive models to
help target the the patrols and the
enforcement and answers yeah that's part
of what's going into when I mentioned
them pay Guardian went away and it's
going to something bigger that's
basically what it is I'm also working
with an individual that has done it for
drone technology so they've they did it
to try and help find where like rhino
poachers would be so we can do similar
things with illegal fishing so yeah
once you're fine if you go fishing what
do you do about it so the question is
once you find someone's like illegal
fishing what do you do about it that's a
that's a particularly loaded question
the the the first step is finding it
which we're not doing right now so
that's where my efforts are focused
right currently if you can gather enough
objective evidence of what's going on
and kind of proved to people other than
it just being you know an arbitrary
fisherman saying he saw this happening
then you could start to change the
legislation around it and start to put
pressure on on the government's to do
more about it there's already some
pressure being done but we're like way
early in the process you know we weren't
documenting it well in the first place
and so a lot of the projects that I
worked on we're focused much more on how
you fix that problem first once you
document it then then like you know how
do you kind of make sure that that stuff
sticks and enforcement gets strong
enough to deter people from doing it
from there so so typically the way that
it would happen is if you could prove
someone's doing it then they would they
would get arrested and their stuff to
get confiscated they'd probably get
fined or the boat would be destroyed it
depends the laws differ from country to
country but but there's some countries
are starting to collaborate and work
together on this sort of thing they have
regional management organizations that
are kind of addressing this sort of
thing but everything's different right
now the way every country does it is
differently if everyone did it like the
u.s. it'd be fine but the US has spy
satellites and all sorts of stuff all
over the place that we see and US had
just barely started to care very
strongly about illegal fishing Obama had
put out a proclamation about it this
year but before that you know they would
basically be looking for for like drug
trafficking and things like that and if
they ended up finding someone doing some
kind of a wildlife crime and the drug
thing or human trafficking then they
would it would get them there but a lot
of my efforts are trying to see how to
standardize that across the countries
and especially if you can standardize it
across the countries that don't have as
much resources as like the you
in canada and UK and people like that
countries like that then then you can
raise the bar and change the way we do
things okay thank you
you